welcome back my next guest has spent the
last two years in a living nightmare
after being falsely accused of rape by a
woman he barely knew Jordan trengrove
was just 18 when he met Elena Williams
on lights out in Cumbria in 2019 what
happened next landed him in prison for
10 weeks left him branded a rapist
destroyed his mental health Eleanor
Williams has since been unmasked as an
evil fantasist and a Serial liar and
today she was jailed for eight and a
half years we've always been to Jordan
let's just hear what he had to say last
time he's on the show back in January
I took an overdose in front of my own
mum it was that bad I didn't ever put
other people's feelings first if you get
what I mean because
my life was just too messed up
with all this stuff
it's Jordan then this is Jordan now
Jordan obviously key of you today when I
heard about the the sentencing
um just wonder what your reaction was
given this scale of the lying and the
fantasy given that so many people like
you were caught up in this web
um do you think it's long enough eight
and a half years
no I don't think it's long enough at all
um I think she should have been given a
lot longer sentence in my eyes because
she's got time served as well so in
reality she's out in 2025 so a sentence
in reality is only two years so I think
she should have got longer when you saw
the the the lengths that she went to you
know buying a how much you've seen on
video buying a hammer to then attack
herself simply so she could frame people
like you for raping her and grooming
here in other cases and so on and
attacking her what did you feel about
that what did you feel watching her just
so calmly going about buying these tools
to create this fantasy
it makes me feel sick I don't know how
anyone would want to do that or want to
hurt herself in any way like that I
couldn't imagine ever hitting myself
with a hammer or anything like that you
you don't want to do anything like that
so it just makes me feel very sick in a
way
the big debate of course is what happens
with cases like this when you have
somebody come forward who's got all
these apparent injuries and makes all
these incendiary claims of assault and
rape and so on
um should the system the legal system
start from a position of believing
accusers or should they start from a
position of listening to the allegations
and then investigating the facts because
in your case you were named on the front
page of a local paper you had rapists
graffitied over your house and you had
to move you were the one who felt
suicidal she meanwhile remained
completely anonymous
yeah I do think that they should be
listened to and taken into account and
regarding like newspapers and being in
the newspapers I think that should be
changed because that was one of the main
things as well what went towards
destroying my life I shouldn't have been
named in that paper when I was on the
remanded you know like fair enough if I
was convicted
yeah I mean you know when I think about
the scale of what she did and I heard
the sentence and like you say you know
if she behaves herself in prison she'll
be out in the next two years you know to
me I don't understand why she didn't get
a life sentence frankly
I think the exact same I think she
should have been given life preventing
the course of Justice can hold the
maximum of life and she's destroyed so
many lives not only mine so she should
have her life took away from her
Jordan how have you got on with
rebuilding your life now has it helped
having her now be named identified and
jailed for lying and you be associated
with that as people know you know you've
been able to go back to your place where
you grew up and people treating you now
as an innocent victim rather than as a
supposed rapist
um I don't like going into barrels so
much anymore I don't like going anywhere
near that town and said to my partner
after the sentencing I said this gives
us two years to just move out the area
because I don't want to be in the area
when she's released as it is but it's I
can rebuild my life now and I've started
like last time I seen you I've been
doing steps towards rebuilding my life
yes I have
if you had been found guilty
of the allegations that she made against
you
as you've been told by a lawyer how long
you may have to have served
I think my solicitor told me back then
it had been looking at like 22 years
because of the severity of it you see
that that to me is just extraordinary
isn't it you were told you might get 22
years in prison for a pack of lies about
you and the person that perpetrated the
lies ends up getting eight and a half
literally about a third
exactly and I think it's so unfair
because if I was sent to prison it had
been so many more years and this is
exactly what I said to quite a lot of
the press when it came out of court
today if I was sent to prison I'm guilty
on what she accused me of it had been a
lot longer
but she can go out and Destroy and
fabricate and do so many people's life
or damage and pretty much just get a
slap on the wrist it just shows it's
very I don't know it's not it's messed
up in the system
yeah I mean to me it's grotesquely
unfair and imbalanced Jordan really
appreciate you coming back on tonight
must have been a difficult day for you
but ultimately I guess a satisfying one
that she at least uh is remaining behind
bars for another two years or so but
like you say ridiculous that then you
have to fear going back to where you
want you're from because you're worried
that she'll be there again which she
will be in two years it seems ridiculous
um I really appreciate you coming back
Jordan thank you very much
thank you very much
all right Ava this guy I've interviewed
him a couple of times now he's so like
impressively calm eloquent but there's a
kind of searing anger there too about
what he's had to endure 18 years old
I've got three sons in my 20s this is
every parent's nightmare for a son now
I'm very aware that a lot of women that
make allegations of sexual sort of rape
get no justice the the rates of of
conviction for these things are
ridiculously low I totally agree with
that but for the purposes of this debate
it's specifically about what's happened
to him
to me it seems ludicrous to carry on
with this notion that all accusers
should be believed we saw it with the
nasty Nick character who invented all
the stories the pedophile stories about
you know some of the most eminent people
in the country we've seen it now with
this woman so we've seen it from a man
and woman to me there should never be a
presumption of belief why should there
be I think that gosh I don't really know
where to begin with I mean we live in a
country where under one percent of you
know rapes even go to conviction so I'm
quite taken aback by what you said why
should you automatically believe an
allegation because we live in a country
where women aren't believed and it is
extremely difficult for women to come
forward and talk about sexual assault
that has happened to them and look this
situation is grotesque you were right to
call it that it's abhorrent and he's a
very nice guy but it's quite clear that
the girl in question is really unwell if
you look at her mental health all around
this case she was reported missing one
year 32 times in in just one year by her
own mother she's clearly not well I
actually don't even think she should be
going to prison I think she's moving I
think she should be sectioned I think
she's not well and I actually don't
think prison is a safe environment for
her but I don't really care if it's a
safe environment for her frankly and I
don't think that being on well as a
justification you wouldn't be saying
justification this might be an
explanation if we had a male if this guy
had been convicted of what he'd been
charged or accused of doing and arrested
over like you said 22 years you'd have
called him a monster he wouldn't have
made some excuse about his mental health
yeah I mean why are you making excuse
for her I'm not giving her an excuse you
are I said you shouldn't even be
impressed I'm explaining I think I don't
think that she is well and I don't think
she's going to be rehabilitated in a
prison I actually think it's going to be
really awful for her and actually as an
indictment of our justice system she
wasn't indictment is that he would have
gone down for 22 years she's going to be
out in the next two years having served
half of the night and a half years this
is going to be any better she's not
going to be any better for it prisoners
about Rehabilitation she is you wouldn't
be saying that if he had been found
guilty and gone to prison for rape
no I think that's a full
Circle he just told you he was told if
these lies stuck and he and he was found
guilty 22 years in prison you would have
been quite happy with that right if she
got through the Justice if he was
convicted and the justice system had
convicted him yes
I've been quite happy here's the Dilemma
for me
I do think it's completely wrong that so
few rape allegations end up with
convictions when in many cases we know
they're probably true so this is a
absolute disgrace in this country about
what happens to women who make
legitimate claims and the system lets
them down I think we can all agree on
that right but this is a different area
this is the area of what the police do
when somebody comes and says XYZ and I
feel strongly now after several very
high profile cases you cannot make a
presumption of belief you cannot call
them victims from the start because they
may not be they might be fantasies but
surely appears there's a difference
between belief and listening to someone
yes seriously investigating it by people
who are really so that's what I said
qualify that's my business and I think
David thinks that's outrageous look
you've got genuinely looked at me in
total discussion yeah she was but but I
think that's because you didn't consider
the point about seriously listening
properly investigating by real
Specialists who understand the
likelihood I know a guy who uh he um
luckily he did remain anonymous but he
had 18 months of absolute hell on Earth
right uh and it turned it went all the
way through trial and at the end of the
trial during 10 minutes uh right and in
this case in this case this poor kid
he's not even 20. and his name is
branded in all his local town as a
rapist of a local paper front page she
meanwhile remains completely Anonymous
yes now I know the argument for the
police is if you name people who are
accused of sexual assault rape it
encourages other people to come forward
exactly but actually why should he be
named and shamed in that circumstance
and a woman like that remain anonymous
until she's finally charged with lying
so this is about what happens in our
minds if you work in family law I do but
this is about what happens in my mind
he's not named and shamed but he was
he's named and it's literally people
Dawn rapist and it's the approach that's
taken by people because we have to all
remember that you are innocent until
proven guilty and unfortunately we
forget that in society and Christopher
Jeffries is a classic example he was the
unfortunate landlord
um who went on to later sue the press
and certain individuals who behave
recklessly and I was one of them at the
time no no defense for that absolutely
lutely and so this is about our
responsibility as a society knowing what
we know and we saw it with that poor
missing woman recently who disappeared
exactly everyone racing to conclusions
about that exactly
the woeful police handling I can
possibly answer but the point is we all
have to take responsibility in a society
where human beings are running a system
should we believe accusers from the
start absolutely it's not about
believing accuses it is because if you
if you believe them you call them if you
call them has failed if you call them
that guy that guy Nick who who invented
all the stories right yeah he was
believed and in fact the the commander
of the Met police at the time called him
a victim right at the moment a policeman
of that rank calls somebody a victim
there is a presumption of guilt and a
presumption that everything he's saying
is true yes and it turned out it was all
complete fantasy and I think you can
avoid all this if you say look someone
comes with navigation and you say right
well take him a seriously we absolutely
will treat you with due respect we'll
take all the details downward properly
investigate then it's then it's
compellingly important that the police
investigate it properly but only at the
point that you have enough to charge
somebody in my belief should anyone even
be considered to be named and shamed
right and that is technically what
should happen that's not what happens
but exactly and why not because people
talk the police will inform them
why is what I'm saying wrong because you
you can name two people two men that
this has happened to can you name all of
the thousands of women who can't get a
conviction why is it going to be either
or you're making it an either one
actually you are you are you are I'm so
I'm not I'm saying there should be a
presumption of an allegations being made
not a presumption of a true allegation
do you know what a woman has to go
through do you know what a woman has to
do to record a rape would you want if
you had a daughter would you want her
having to give her knickers over
all right would you like her to give her
underwear but I think you are completing
two different things I'm not convicting
what's that got to do with the
presumption of innocence or guilt no
because right now we are talking about
and has ruined someone's life and it is
grotesque comparing that to women who
are assaulted and should be believed why
would she believed so that they can go
through the process
and why was he disbelieved because she
was a woman reporting a sexual assault
she also did turn up because she was
hammered to her face and she did look
like she had been assaulted right the
police did let him down I will say that
the piece in this situation why is it
sensible to just believe accusers I
don't even think we can have that
conversation because actually victims
are never believed it's very rare that
they are this is just a high profile
case where a woman
unfortunately has been believed wrongly
Richard we've just got to have higher
quality Specialists who've got more
experience about assessing these and
quickly where's the money for that
Richard
we've got to find
you know what it's complicated but I do
think there have been too many of these
cases now and the problem starts if you
just say I believe you from the start
rather than I listen to you which is
what happens in every other form of
crime right pretty much
right why do we just assume people are
telling the truth
why listen and investigate properly
exactly treat with respect absolutely
listen to them seriously then
investigate otherwise you get into this
kind of situation which I think is
incredibly unfair the problem is when
the system is so backed up against those
who let's all agree the system the
system is deeply flawed and it has to be
and the conviction rates are a disgrace